In October 2017, a steel Rolex sells for
seventeen point eight million dollars.
It belongs to the story of a movie star, a racing driver,
and a young man working on a treehouse.
Why did Paul Newman's Rolex sell for so much?
The answer begins with a gift.
The watch has no diamonds.
Its case is stainless steel.
It is a chronograph: a watch with a stopwatch built in.
You can start it, stop it, and measure an interval.
There is useful machinery here.
But useful machinery alone doesn't explain that number.
To understand it, follow the watch through the hands of
the people who wore it.
Before the bidding, before the collectors, there was a
husband whose wife wanted him to drive carefully.
Rolex introduced the Cosmograph in 1963.
The Daytona name tied the watch to motor racing.
A driver might want to measure a lap.
A crew member might want to compare one run with another.
The chronograph gives them an interval; the scale around
the bezel can turn a measured interval into an average
speed over a known distance.
For example, one mile in thirty seconds works out to one
hundred and twenty miles per hour.
That's a calculation, not a story about Newman setting a
lap record. The idea is easy to grasp: make
time something you can use.
Newman's watch was a reference six two three nine.
You wound it by hand.
A small mechanical routine, repeated day after day.
Then a very personal message changed the meaning of that
racing instrument.
Joanne Woodward, Newman's wife and fellow actor, gave him
the Daytona. The back carried four words:
“Drive Carefully Me.” The wording is
wonderfully compact. A driving instruction,
followed by a personal sign-off.
Their film Winning connected Newman with the world of
racing, and his interest continued beyond the production.
The watch fit that new part of his life.
Think of the difference between a gift in a shop window
and a gift after years of use.
In the window, you see a model.
Once someone has worn it, you begin to see a
relationship. The inscription gives that relationship a
physical place to live.
And racing was about to supply much more than a glamorous
backdrop. Newman went from playing a driver to
competing against them.
In 1979, Newman raced at the twenty-four hours of
Le Mans. He shared a Porsche nine thirty-five with
Dick Barbour and Rolf Stommelen.
They finished second overall and won their class.
Second overall. In a race that lasted a full day.
That is a useful answer to anyone tempted to treat the
racing as a movie-star hobby with a camera
nearby. The achievement belongs to a team, and
the watch wasn't driving the car.
But it gives the wider story substance.
Newman had entered the world that the chronograph was
designed to serve. Now imagine seeing photographs of an
actor you recognize, in a setting where timing matters,
with a distinctive watch on his wrist.
The association becomes easy to remember.
Soon his name would help people identify an entire kind
of Daytona. Which creates a surprisingly important
problem for our story.
A Paul Newman Daytona does not necessarily mean a Daytona
owned by Paul Newman.
Collectors use the name for particular exotic dials.
These have distinctive details, including contrasting
tracks and small square-ended markers inside the
counters. Rolex itself describes the connection
between the actor and that dial design.
So the nickname can travel.
Several watches can carry it.
Personal ownership cannot travel in the same way.
Another watch might share a reference number, a dial
style, or a period of manufacture.
Those similarities don't give it Newman's history.
Keep two questions separate: what kind of watch is this,
and whose watch was this?
The auction would eventually bring both answers together.
But first, the original watch moved away from Newman's
wrist, through an exchange that had nothing to do with an
auction catalogue.
In the summer of 1984, James Cox was dating
Newman's daughter Nell. He was working on a treehouse at
the family's home in Connecticut.
The account published by Phillips, drawing on Nell's
letter, describes Newman asking Cox for the time.
Cox didn't have a watch.
Newman gave him the Daytona.
Cox later described the exchange in his own interview.
He remembered Newman showing him how to wind it.
He also remembered wearing it for years.
That's the turning point.
For a collector looking backward, the object carries a
famous name. For the person receiving it, the connection
is immediate: someone he knows has handed him
something personal. A wife gives a watch to her husband.
The husband gives it to a young man connected to his
family. Two gifts. One watch.
And a history that would need to be established before
anyone could bid on it.
Ownership history has a name in the collecting world:
provenance. It means the documented path an object
has taken. Without that path, a famous-owner
claim is just a claim.
The Phillips lot record identified the reference, case
number and engraving. It also listed an
attestation letter signed by Nell Newman.
Those details anchored the story to one physical watch.
They matter because resemblance is easy to offer.
A connection to a particular person needs evidence.
Picture two visually similar objects placed side by side.
One comes with a known family history and identifying
details. The other comes with a promising story that you
cannot check. The difference isn't visible in the hands
on the dial. For this auction, the history was central
to the offer. The next question was what bidders
would pay for it.
By now, the number in the opening has a more recognizable
shape. There is the watch itself: a vintage
racing chronograph with a distinctive dial.
There is the association: Newman, the actor and
driver whose name became attached to that design.
And there is the ownership story of this particular
example. Those layers meet in a single object.
You can find another chronograph.
You can find another exotic dial.
You cannot give another watch the same past.
That helps explain the attraction.
It doesn't tell us exactly how much each bidder assigned
to each part of the story.
There is no honest equation that turns a marriage, a
racing career and a family gift into a precise dollar
amount. The auction supplied a price through competition.
In October 2017, that competition began with a number
that made the earlier estimate look very small.
Phillips had estimated the watch at one to two million
dollars. The first bid was ten million: five
times the top of that estimate.
According to the auction house, the contest lasted twelve
minutes. A telephone bidder won.
The published result, including the buyer's premium, was
seventeen million, seven hundred and fifty-two thousand,
five hundred dollars. The buyer's premium
is the auction house's charge added to the winning bid.
The headline number is the total result, not
the hammer price alone.
At the time, it was a world auction record for a
wristwatch. The watch's history helps explain why
bidders were interested. Their competition explains how
the price was reached.
It is still one sale, on one day.
It doesn't establish what another Daytona should cost, or
what this one would bring in a future auction.
The sale also carried a charitable connection.
Phillips said a portion of the proceeds would support the
Nell Newman Foundation and Newman's Own Foundation.
The catalogue did not give that portion a percentage.
Newman's philanthropy had a much longer history.
In 1982, he and A.
E. Hotchner founded Newman's Own, a food company whose
profits supported charitable causes.
So the watch connects several parts of a life: work,
racing, family and giving.
The price makes it famous as an object.
The two gifts make its history memorable.
For this story, the most revealing detail is still the
smallest. Four words on the back, from one person to
another. Drive carefully. Me.